we are all writers now whether you want
to write a book or a blog or better text
messages or emails I want to help you
with a free ebook call it 11 ways to
write better you can find that at the
minimalists com slash resources enjoy
and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist to say we're going to talk
about organizing we're gonna talk about
tidying up we're gonna talk about
cleaning your home with today's guest
Melissa maker is here from
cleanmyspace.com Melissa thank you for
joining us I'm really happy that you're
here today because I think you sort of
formed this date on between the
organizers and Ryan and I have spoken it
like professional organizer events and
watching the videos in your channel
Jessica first sent them to me and I'm
like oh she gets it
cuz Ryan and I will often say like the
easiest way to organize your space is to
own fewer items and you understand that
but also you understand that
organization even with having fewer
things is still important organizing is
not the answer though it's not just well
we need to go to the Container Store and
spend $1400 and then we're gonna put all
of our junk in our basement nice
container the problem is we don't have
enough storage containers or or we need
a storage unit yeah our first question
today is from a muna in Columbus Ohio hi
my name is Emunah Marie I'm calling from
Columbus Ohio I'm interested in pursuing
the minimalist lifestyle and I'm
wondering how you can work that out if
you happen to be married to a packrat
well I'm sure you deal with this people
who live with pack rats or they
themselves or pack rats are different
from their significant other I know my
my wife and I aren't exactly the same
either and so it's all varying degrees
here but when you run across this how do
you how do you talk to people about
dealing with a pack rat in their family
kindly
because you're Canadian well but really
I mean when somebody is holding on to
stuff we all know that that's an
emotional response we know that there's
something deeper we know there's a
reason why they're holding onto it it
could be a financial thing a fear thing
a sadness thing and anger thing we don't
know it could be a family thing there's
could be guilt involved so it's not the
symptom the stuff that we have to talk
about
it's what's really going on and how can
we find ways to work together to part
with some of this stuff
it is very overwhelming at first which
is why this situation has to be dealt
with kid gloves like the person I'm unna
would have to be very delicate in the
way that she speaks to her partner about
that because it can feel offensive it
can it can hit you where it hurts yeah I
think that also you have to realize a
moment like I'm not how old you are but
let's say you're 30 years old how long
did it take you to stumble across
simplicity or or minimalism and then
finally embrace it maybe it took you 30
years or maybe when you first saw it
maybe you saw our documentary or you
read a Marie Kondos book or something
like that and you realized like oh maybe
this is something I'd like to consider
but how long did it actually take for
you to embrace it and oh by the way were
you ready for that message when you
found it maybe someone else in your
family isn't necessarily ready for that
message yet and so I think that kindness
is also giving them the space that they
need not to force the change but to be
the sort of leader of the change in
showing showing the benefits that they
often appear from letting go or
organizing or tidying up what are some
of those benefits that you find and I
know you talk about it in a lot of your
videos over on your YouTube channel but
let's talk about some of the benefits of
of well cleaning the space obviously
obviously we know it's easier to clean
when there's less stuff there's less
there's less dust there's less dirt less
things to move when you're you know
vacuuming under a surface or putting
something away I just like under the bed
if you have a ton of stuff under the bed
how hard is it to actually clean under
the bed
becomes impossible right not that I'm a
Feng Shui person but according to Feng
Shui it's not good to have stuff under
your bed mmm thank you my snowboards ooh
well maybe if you took them out some
really good things maybe well I have a
loft so like it's there's very little
which we don't need a lot of storage
space but the snow words I totally stash
underneath the bed I don't know what
I'll put him on the roof I guess I don't
know I find you know when I walked in
and so full disclosure I hate cleaning I
still do and that's always been my thing
and you know I've just found over the
years that cleaning is is it it's sort
of an act of self-love I take care of
myself when I keep my space clean tweet
that so that's pithy
yeah cleaning is an act of self-love I
love it so you know I think taking care
of myself by cleaning even though I
don't love it it makes when I come home
that much more enjoyable I can relax
I can recharge I can calm down whereas
on the flip side when you come in in
your house is a mess and scattered and
there are things everywhere there's no
way you can relax no matter what kind of
day you've had you can't come home you
can't be in your zone you know you can't
just recharge and let go of things it
doesn't work because you look in the
corner and you'll see a sock then you'll
see dust then you'll see this and then
things start to pile up and the anxiety
builds yeah I totally agree like out
yeah I mean with the munna the I know
that she wants to relax and I know her
partner wants to relax and that's what I
have written down the advice for Munir's
like start with the this the
commonalities that you both have like
what do you both want that's a great
place to start they both want to relax
so how can they get to that point I
think and I've been there when you know
I have a partner who has something going
on in their life or a habit and I'm like
why do you do that you know this is this
is not what I want and this is you know
this is different and I don't like it
like and that is like - starting with
the difference is right Twitter by right
yeah different I don't like it different
I don't like it but it's I mean that's
what I project when what I have found
especially with like Moriah like I mean
this is the best relationship I've ever
been in that we we go out of our way to
find the commonalities and then work
towards those commonalities and setting
up like pointing if
on each other and I'll tell you like
that to me that is when you know you
have a good relationship or good
romantic relationship is when you have a
partner that you actually want to go out
of your way to like meet their work
requirements or their preferences maybe
that's a better way of saying it
so for Mariah like I love her so much
that I want her to be happy so I'm
willing to compromise on you know some
small things like nothing you know major
I'm not gonna kill puppies for but uh
but but there are some things that I
compromise but I'm happy to do it
because I love her so much and there's
no there's no perfect relationship at
least if I haven't found it if there is
one out there I'm sure there is one out
there where it's just like easy breezy
and both people are on the same page but
I have never experienced that myself
Mariah and you're eventually going to be
on a different page of course you're on
the same page you're gonna find
something where you're like yeah my
preferences are obviously different from
yours by the way that's the thing that
makes a relationship fun and exciting
and alive is in fact you have some
variety between two people as long as
that variety doesn't have to do with
your morals with your ethics or with
your values then you realize like oh
yeah we of course we have some
differences and then we have to deal
with some of those differences I really
love what you said though about the
commonality we actually did a video a
long time ago about it was such an
interesting question it was how to get
your spouse to clean and actually it was
actually how to get your husband to
clean that was the question we kept
getting asked but we went gender-neutral
a long time ago so we actually just I
forget if it was partner or spouse but
that's the terminology that we use and
finding common ground was one of the
first things that we talked about
because you have to meet in the middle
somewhere and there has to be a starting
point one of the things that you are
both such big proponents of is this is a
journey it's not like I feel this way
today and I'm getting there tomorrow and
I feel the same way there's so much that
she will have to work through with her
partner it has to be a journey so you
know opening his or her mind to what
could be the possibilities what could be
out there how would life be without this
much stuff what are some materials that
you can watch or read or listen to how
do you feel about that start bringing
that into the conversation so
clutter the symptom I think it's gonna
take a while to work that out I think a
lot of it has to happen up here first
yeah I mean the best thing a Munna can
do is respect her partner's battle that
they're going through I mean you know
he's like you said there's some
emotional trauma or not trauma but
there's something emotional going on
there's probably some sort of traumatic
event or incite so the best way muda can
get him to start coming to her side is
by respecting that battle that he has so
yes be kind find the commonalities that
I mean just respect as all people want
out of any relationship I think you
don't always have to meet in the middle
right now you might have to meet him
where he is in order to understand where
he is and what you're doing there as a
leader if you're if you're going to be
the leader in this situation you often
have to meet people where they are and
then lead them away from where they are
now you do that through your behaviors
not through your words you can't say
well all right now you need to clean
this up obviously right and the video
that you mention most so let's put a
link to that Shawn in the show notes we
could find that and that way folks can
can take a look at that as well
Anna Mona I'd love to send you a copy of
Melissa's book it's called clean my
space which you can also find at
cleanmyspace.com and we'll send you a
copy of that our next question is from
Caitlin in Pittsburgh hello my name is
Caitlin Greg
I am from Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and I
wanted to know what your thoughts were
on keeping a hold of stuff like your a
certificate in social security colors
was the best was the best type of way to
store these things Melissa let's talk
about paperwork because she mentioned
two things and I think everyone is
either going to hold on today I just got
a new social security card myself and
dude I just ordered a social security
card and when I did they try to talk me
out of it why did you get that when you
ordered it like on the Social Security
website they were like do you actually
need a social security card
think about it there's very few
situations a lot of the times when they
ask for a social security card there's
something else that will supplement it
I think someone stole your identity no
man it really was on the Social Security
website maybe they took that off but but
yeah so there are some things I mean I
have it so the explain how I do
love to actually talk to an expert about
this and it's always melissa here but I
have a file cabinet and I have it's a
locked file cabinet such a phony no you
have a filing cabinet you cut yourself
one of the minimalist and and in there I
have a file with important documents
like my life insurance things that need
to be printed out and most of my
paperwork however is digitized and Ryan
and I share a scanner well Ryan Sean
Jordan and anyone else who wants to
borrow the scanner we we share a paper
scanner so in a photo scanner it's the
same thing put a link to that in the
show notes as well Sean the scanner that
we use it's relatively inexpensive and
it has alleviated the need for 95% of
the paper because as Ryan just said most
of the the papers that we need now
they're fine if they're digitized there
are a few things where it makes sense to
have a printed out copy but even then
you should have it digitized because
what if you know the house burns down or
something happens it's important to have
some sort of backup somewhere and I
think the problem isn't though Caitlin
your birth certificate social security
card those two things are gonna fit in
one file and you're fine tape them to
the snowboard yeah fine but I think that
what happens is we then develop the same
mindset around everything well I need to
have 17 years of tax records and I have
to well no you probably don't in fact
even the tax records you could you do
need to have whatever it is seven years
in the United States but those can be
digitized as well you don't have to have
the printed out version of it in fact
everything like that is being digitized
now so I say digitize wherever you can
and they're gonna be a few items and
they'll fit it in fact my file cabinet
it's absurd like there's it's maybe 1/4
full of papers and the rest of it is
just empty and that's because unless I
absolutely need to store it in there and
I go through and I'll clean it out at
the beginning of each year
I just don't print it out anymore so
first of all sounds like you can sell
that filing cabinet and downsize I
finally got a so I so I run three
businesses and three of them so two are
out of my house one of them is out of a
space quite like what you're in we've
digitized that business and we've
reduced significantly the amount of
paper that we use I love this question
because it sounds so great but it is so
overwhelming when you think about how
you're going to do it so having a really
small filing cabinet for those valuable
things life insurance passport any
important documents that you'll need SSN
whatever I could even be a lockbox
so we actually keep our stuff in a safe
okay and if I are proof safe and then
our business stocks that we do need and
some other you know health forms that
kind of thing we will keep that in a
filing cabinet but I go through it every
year and one of my favorite things in my
house is a paper shredder okay yeah is
anything that comes with my name address
that gets shredded any documents that I
don't need anymore it goes right into
the shredder it's fun it's pleasurable
like you wash it there's something very
satisfying about watching so that's
great and then digitizing is key so
wanted so a couple things I want to
point out retexe so the first one is
there's a great app that you can get I
think it's free it's called the Adobe
scan app so you don't even need a
scanner you can actually just use your
phone as a scanner so that's awesome I
use that a lot with business if I have
to sign a doc and send it off to someone
I will use that app the other thing now
that I have I have an Apple pencil with
my iPad so I feel Oh fell out a lot of
Doc's just using that particular tech
and then I save it it goes right to the
cloud
I have not printed out so much paper
using that particular format it has been
wonderful no you have a daughter as well
and she's less than two at this point so
there's paperwork involved with that as
well right can we talk a little bit
about that
in record yeah I'm gonna keep that you
know but other other things that come
through like her daycare even sends all
of their notes and handbooks and
everything through PDF hmm so had they
not done that I either would have
requested a copy or I would have read it
made any pertinent notes in my calendar
and then just gotten rid of it when
things come in I always say to myself am
I going to need this like if I were to
get audited no what I need it right if I
don't it goes in this shredder if
something were to happen there was a
flood would I need this document yes I
would so it has to be accessible but
like my car insurance policy from 2016
by it's all about just paying very close
attention to what the purpose of that
document is do I need a physical copy of
it and if I don't
can I digitize it great and making sure
that everything's current cuz the second
you don't need it I always think about
things like why why am I paying a
mortgage or rent for you right yeah why
is this document why am i paying a
mortgage to house that document I'm
isolating your stuff exactly yeah it's
funny and so if you get a bunch of junk
mail - you can obviously shred it app
that I use is called paper Karma I'm
familiar with paper Karma okay so so the
the app is just called I don't know if
it works in Canada I assume it does but
it's it's called paper Karma's an app
and you snap a photo the mail they send
you and it automatically unsubscribe to
you from from the list yeah and with
with my daughter as my daughter got
older she's six now and she'll bring
home artwork and stuff and so this is
another type of paper you have to deal
with right now with us Ryan you noticed
this when you were babysitting her last
we have one piece of artwork on on the
fridge yeah and that and if she wants to
replace it then she has to remove that
one and put the new one up now we'll
take a picture of the old one just like
all right now Ella you need to shred
that immediately get rid of this memory
therapy in 25 years but what we do is we
help her better understand like the the
memory or the experience is not in
things we talked to her about that but
also make her go through the the
experience of lightening we're not gonna
hoard all of this stuff but also it's ok
to have a small for a kid to have a
small collection of her artwork or a
stack of these things but there is
always going to be a limit and as
parents we get to draw that limit the
the kids can have some input but
ultimately if you give them if you give
them all the input then it's going you
know it's gonna be tyranny within your
household yeah yeah I would kaitlin's
who don't let don't let this little
thing like hang you up I know if
Kaitlyn's like me these little things
like prevent me from taking any action
because they are so overwhelming but
yeah it's don't freak yourself out too
bad so we talked about living well
versus if Achatz or social security card
immunization records like what else
death documents so go to the minimalists
comm slash death we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well there is
a essay they are called scared to death
of death and because we we we actually
don't talk about these things it's
really unfortunate I have some close
friends whose parents are in the later
stages of their life and they still
refuse to talk about like well do I want
to be cremated and like in my wallet I
have just a little card that says you
know do not resuscitate and I'm an organ
donor and all of these these things and
you can set yourself up for success so
that you you you and your family know
exactly what you want you could have a
living will you can have a last will and
testament you you can have all of these
documents and so there are some
important documents there that give you
a peace of mind so you don't have to
worry about it once you set it up then
you'll feel good about the fact that you
and your loved ones know your wishes
when you die now in my will it says Ryan
can do whatever he want he can cut my
head off and use it as a soccer ball
things I'm gonna do things I'm gonna do
this is I could be shot out of a cannon
it's it's fun to inject some comedy into
that too because it is some of the the
the most serious things that we talk
about but quite often the life's most
serious challenges can be talked about
only through jokes one other thing I do
want to put in there something we call
scanning party so put a link to that in
the show notes as well Shawn having a
photo scanner or a a digital scanner in
general having some friends over to scan
all the old photos and and put them in a
digital picture frame instead of them
just sitting in your attic or closet and
collecting dust and no one's getting a
way out of them you can find your
favorites you can store them in a
digital scanner and by the way if your
house ever does burn down or you have a
flood then they're backed up in the
cloud you still have access to all those
old photos that you scanned you're
actually using them now so a scanning
party is definitely something I would
recommend Caitlin I'm gonna send you a
copy of our book essential it's the
essay collection with 150 different
essays twelve different areas of
intentional living I think you'll find a
lot of value in two of the chapters in
particular there's a chapter about stuff
which is gonna be important for you but
also a chapter about minimalism and the
philosophy around minimalism so if you
enjoy our podcast you'll enjoy the
audiobook version of essential or if you
want the book book or the e-book we're
happy to send those to you as well Ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it it's time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media we do indeed we are at the
minimalists on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram Louis what were your what are
your handles on social were you out on
the social medias I'm at I'm at Melissa
maker and @cleanmyspace
there you go awesome we'll put a link to
your website in the show notes as well
so people can find you over there Ryan
what question we got your first question
is from Mika I've given up hope my dirty
cluttered house just sits there and I
just sit and stare at it I have creative
plans but there's a mountain between me
and those plans what should I do about
my stasis now so here's the thing
there's a mountain of stuff that's what
she's seeing but the the that's the
almost literal mountain or at least of
the physical manifestation but the real
mountain is
there's a psychological mountain right
you know that I mean that's what it is
it's it's the procrastination it's
there's so much to do I don't know where
to start so I'm not going to start and
then creative plans get put on hold and
then a week a month a year passes our
house isn't any cleaner and our creative
pursuits haven't gone any further for
that reason so I think first and
foremost and I heard you speak about
this earlier when you were answering
Caitlin's question it's sort of like you
have to stare the ugly things in the
face like you have to stare death in the
face you have to stare not in that way
but like dealing with the documents you
know we did our last will and testament
to it was a horrible process when you
think about it but then you get it done
and it wasn't as bad as you thought it
was and those documents are in our safe
and we don't have to think about it
anymore so that's nice but you know in
this situation with Myka what it comes
down to is saying what needs to be done
I'm a list person so you know my book I
talk about it like put a list together
then I have what I call my M IAS my most
important areas so think about what your
most important areas are start with that
put five minutes put one episode of this
podcast on clean for that amount of time
and start chipping away one bit at a
time because you can't look at your
whole house I find people when they get
their most overwhelmed it's because
they're looking at the big picture and
they're like I can't do this sorry the
entire elephant can't eat the entire
elephant one bite at a time you talked
about rastan ation and there's one thing
that often says is don't let your crafts
donation turn pro and that's that's kind
of what we've done here I've got a pithy
answer for you here oh by the way we try
to collect all of our pithy answers and
put them in the show notes Shawn does
and then Jessica puts all of our minimal
Maxim's in one place at minimal Maxim's
calm here's here's my pitty answer you
cannot get where you're going without
moving from where you are so I think
that's where Mika is right now she's
she's sort of stuck where she is and she
wants to be somewhere else she wants to
be on the other side of the mountain of
stuff right but just wishing you're on
the other side of the mountain without
beginning the journey you're just
keep wishing in perpetuity yeah it's not
a good place to be I also want to say
that unlike diet or exercise cleaning
you get results immediately like this so
if you put in 5 10 15 30 minutes of
cleaning yeah you will see visible
results instantly and that can even
encourage you to want to you know go on
and pursue a little bit more cleaning
yeah if you're in an entire house that
when you've given up hope and and is
there a place where you're like here's
here's the best bang for your buck okay
you know a powder room or a front
entryway just a small space where when
you put the time in you'll actually see
the results after because if you tackle
a huge room like you know your kitchen
or your bedroom you might feel like oh
my gosh this is gonna take three hours
maybe you don't have it in you to do
three hours at the beginning yeah so
maybe you just have to start with a
small space first and then at the end
you really need to celebrate that yeah
like you have to look at it and say wow
you know take a picture send it to your
friends whatever it is that you have to
do reward is really important as well
and just feeding that that positivity so
you know seeing what you've done feeling
really good about it and affirming that
to yourself and just riding high on that
like that's what like when I'm
struggling with cleaning that's what I
have to do I have to look at the space
and say wow that felt really good
where else can I apply this energy yes
yeah I totally agree it makes me think
about I had to paint our trailer in high
school and like that's how I how I did
it just one little piece at a time I
remember like looking at the whole
trailer and I'm like oh crap I'm never
gonna get this done right but then I was
like all right I'm just gonna start with
this one wall today and if I can get
this wall done I'll feel good about
myself
what's a single wide or a double wide
it's double wide it was a nice double
way to my pit the answer is this when
you're hopeless find someone who's
hopeful so Mika you might be down and
out right now and maybe she's just in a
state of depression and she can't even
you know take those first initial steps
I mean there's a saying Mika sometimes
the bravest action you can take is ask
for help and you might have to seek
someone to help you deal
with that emotional clutter that you
have going on you might have to bring a
friend in and have them help you just
kind of tackle it to tackle it together
yeah you might have to yeah I mean I
really say this and it's kind of half
true like you want to look at some
inspirational things read books listen
to podcasts the problem is that you
don't want to get just stuck in looking
at inspirational things it's a very easy
place to get stuck in videos but then
they they don't actually clean they're
just progression cleaning right so so I
do want you to get some inspiration from
somewhere but if you're at a point where
you've got all the inspiration but you
are still having trouble taking the
action I mean you got asked for help and
there's nothing wrong with asking for
help yeah thinking I had that creative
pursuit that she has maybe that's really
scaring her so as long as she's keeping
herself in the cluttered mess she
doesn't have to go and do the thing that
scares her the most yeah all right
before we get into our added value
segment and our listener tips today it
looks like we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week indeed we do Ryan
let's see how can we make holiday
gatherings flow better with less after
clutter I'm really loving this this new
word after clutter also I'm out of
storage space what should I do with the
new clutter I can't organize we have old
clutter and then the new clutter how can
I be a minimalist as a student with all
the supplies that come with being a
student and how does your physical
environment affect your mental state and
how do I encourage my child's
grandparents it's Heidi up their home
for my own child safety plus just a
million more questions for Melissa maker
plus ten rules for a cleaner home that's
from Melissa and also from Melissa five
secret storage spots in your house and
if you want to hear all that you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right you currently listen to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different much longer
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about
topics we don't usually discuss in
public plus patreon is
best way for us to fund this podcast and
keep it 100% advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you find all the details and all the
good stuff including an additional
private podcast episode every week over
at the minimalists comm slash support
Ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi Justin Ryan
my name is Sandra and I'm from Norway I
would like to share a quote that changed
my view on minimalism I've been on this
journey for about 7 years now and this
month I have been doing my version on
the minimalism game where I tried to let
go of 500 items in total my boyfriend
saw a pair of shoes I was going to sell
and said that they were nice shoes I
told him I agreed but that I didn't know
where them and that it did not add value
to my life anymore
he then said this just because something
is pretty doesn't mean you have to own
it
hey Ryan and Josh this is Muriel from
Grand Haven Michigan I just listened to
episode 210 about student debt I have a
tip related to that topic I wanted to
share I'm currently a senior at Grand
Valley State University and I'll be
graduating this may with no student debt
I've put in a lot of work in many ways
to get to this point but my number one
recommendation for people looking to
avoid student that is to apply for
scholarships specific to who you are
for example I'm studying natural
resources management so I applied to
many scholarships related to my field of
study you can find scholarships based on
your interests academic performance
special talents your major and many
other things I even got a $1,000
scholarship from my credit union there
are scholarships for everything
you just have to intentionally search
out the ones you have the best chance of
getting they may take a long time to
apply for but it's worth the time you
put in if they help you stay out of debt
additionally check to see if your
university has a list of available
scholarships GVSU has a website called
my scholarships where you can create a
profile and they suggest scholarships
specific to you and you can apply for
them directly through the website you
can also search for specific
scholarships there this is what I found
to work for me and I hope some of your
listeners find this helpful
all right Joe thanks again to Melissa
maker for joining us today check her out
clean my space com you can also check
out her YouTube channel we'll put a link
to that in the shows she has over 600
videos on her YouTube channel very
practical very useful very helpful I
think you'll find a lot of value in that
also her book is called clean my space
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast Oh before
that right here right now as a segment
we do we talk about something's going on
life of the minimalists we have two
things for you so talk about our homes
and cleaning your home we have video
tours of both of our homes ryan and so
we both did video tours this year of our
homes and we'll put a link to those
actually just go to our youtube channel
you'll find them right there youtube.com
slash the minimalist you can find a
video tour of my home and my family and
the Ryan and Mariah and their home and
you own a surprisingly little amount of
things I've always considered to be a
messy minimus but your place is not
nearly as messy as I thought the key is
josh is you get rid of everything in
sulk in an empty apartment it's a great
tip pro tip everyone you could tweet
that podcast shot alright if you have a
question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast leave a voicemail for 0 6 2
1 9 7 8 3 9 or send a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm you can
comment on this episode on youtube
channel youtube.com slash the minimalist
if you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our emails over at the
minimalists comm just go there in your
email address at the top you can also
find all of our free wallpapers over
there and a bunch of other resources
articles etc but we'll put our show
notes in your inbox and also send you
our simple Sunday emails anytime those
come out you know we won't send you spam
junk advertisements anything that won't
add value to your life and of course
unsubscribe anytime if it's not adding
value
speaking of adding value for our added
value this week you know rust and Kelly
he's Kacey Musgraves house
and he had one of my favorite albums of
last year and this year he released a
covers album it's a short album it's
maybe nine songs
it's the album itself is called dirt emo
and he sort of takes he's taking these
these 90 songs like teenage dirtbag and
he's covering it in a way where they
actually sound way better than the
original I love when that happens
it isn't that it and it almost like
brings out the it brings us something
about the lyrics you didn't actually
catch the first time dude it reminds me
of Obadiah Parkers hey yeah we did and
you realize how sad that Outkast so good
with it they made that outcasts song
where it's just like hey yeah and it's
all I did when he plays it it's it's
sort of downtrodden yeah and yeah you
noticed different parts of the song that
you normally wouldn't so let's finish
today with teenage dirtbag from Rustin
Kelly's new acoustic covers album that
album is called dirt emo and if you live
here today with with one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus